let's bring you some breaking news now
Virgin Airlines has confirmed that one
of its planes is currently circling
gatwick airport with technical problems
there you can see the flight tracker
website that shows you that the plane
took off around eleven forty this
morning set off on its course and you
can see going down over Bournemouth and
then out across the west of the UK
circling a bit over barnstable and
Biddeford before turning back coming
back at south of the country passports
birth and Brighton to start again
circling get work and that latest image
shows us that it appears to be circling
somewhere over the south coast skies Joe
tidy is here Joe what do we know about
about why this might be happening well
in the last few minutes we had we just
had this from Virgin Atlantic saying the
Virgin Atlantic can confirm that flight
vs 43 on the twenty-ninth of December
travelling to McCarran International
Airport Las Vegas return to London
Gatwick due to a technical issue with
one of the landing gears the aircraft is
preparing to implement a non-standard
landing procedure at Gatwick Airport a
further update will be issued as soon as
possible right so